when you're making this film when you're
making a film in the outdoors which I
mean it's partly a nature film it's
partly an adventure film it one can look
at technique as apart from the content
and so we don't often talk about the
content here because we're filmmakers we
had them you know the traditional method
of would like we interviewed people and
then we had archive incredible archive
and then there was the decision to use
reconstructions of which about eighteen
18 percent of the film is actually
reconstruction so so the techniques
involved in using that and once I
decided that we were going to use
reconstructions there's also am kind of
you know work done to make those look
like they're actually on k2 so there was
it was more than just actually going
into the into the environment and
shooting we used a lot of them speaking
technically processes like green screen
because and specifically in this case I
wanted the mat I we filmed the
reconstructions and the relative safety
of the Eiger in Switzerland at about
4,000 meters and because I wanted to
know ice on all of those things under
and the physical environment for the
actors and the climbers to react to but
because the mountains around us were so
different to the Karakoram region of the
Himalaya where k2 is and i decided to
much of the frustration of ravi ryan the
DP that like anytime we pan around to
see mountains a green screen would go up
and he got it but we'll hang on what's
wrong with those mountains are perfect
yeah he liked his life yeah and he was
like the lovely only no no no no sorry
green screen in and while we were
arguing how to have the grips going put
that in there for you you are making a
big movie here at all but without a big
budget thing hi I always try to make big
movies with him well that's a that's a
great I would also say there was a kind
of forensic aspect to make and doing the
recreations and that we had poured over
these transcripts and what people said
it happened over and over again to try
to figure out the best way we could do
these moments than weren't caught on
film and in fact he's kind of
downplaying the whole thing but pemba
was there for the recreations as where
to place himself plays himself but he
was also there too
confirm how it could have happened what
you know when we were going on all these
different points of view and kind of
creating these scenes we had people who
actually actually were on the mountain
that day telling us you know how they
remembered it so it's a great deal of
material to try to condense into a
narrative so how did you come to then
choose this structure as a writer
particularly well I mean I think that I
think that we from day one wanted to put
people on the mountain immediately and
into the experience of it I don't climb
mountains i would never particularly
after this experience but there's no way
I would do it and I thought the you know
and we thought together talking about it
the what we wanted to do is try to give
people the experience of it and that
would mean you know to not spend 30 or
40 minutes talking about ropes and
crampons and who's going to carry what
and what team is where but rather to get
up there on the mountain and kind of
this really feel like you're a part of
what's going on immediately and when we
committed to that that meant we were
going to play with the structure so so
how did yeah how did you come to this
you are not a filmmaker first so how did
this project come together um well it
was a huge media of story in ireland's
as well I mean the fact that we kind of
focus on Jerry McDonald is purely
accidental and I'm Irish and he's ours
because oh no there's all that RT eight
money come on oh no no no no I mean
truthfully the three out he is what
happened is I mean it was a big media
story as we as we talk about daring
night i know but i but the m but what
happened was is that i'm in very soon
after the events in i'm not a climber
either at all and um so a friend of
chairs and had come and said hey listen
do you know you heard about that story
went yeah and they he had known the
irish climber pat Falvey who had climbed
with jer and pemba in two thousand and
and he said you know you should talk to
him you know
and he brought partying to me and he sat
down and I remember going like I know
nothing about man's what would I be
doing here but I was drawn to the kind
of the extreme nature of the events
itself and then basically part of told
is what had happened on the mountain it
because he'd been in contact with Pam ba
and Pam bow and let me be very clear
pemba wasn't looking to try and have his
story told I mean we had to drag it out
on he's a very reluctant hero you know
to be brutally honest and then he butt
pad had said look you know you know we
have heard of all about this but you
know the nature of 24 7 rolling news
these days means by the time pemba came
out nobody was even picking up on this
so it's just seemed like there was a
certain amount of inequality within the
story that you know struck me in
whatever socialists beliefs i still have
in me you know i mean i think you've
made that right yeah in this you've done
you've made that right now you've given
him a voice Robin and I felt he really
needed a voice and and through to call a
very long story short through
interviewing pemba very shortly after he
brought to light the events of what
happened on the mountain through the
photographs and we kind of went hey hang
on a second so something more it
happened on the mountain that we knew
because you know the media drah ported
the chair just got lost on the mend and
he was hypoxic and he wandered aimlessly
of course which said in train the motion
for their family to be very upset and
wanting you know that you know the truth
to know about their son and so on and so
forth so that was dubs the genesis I
didn't want to just do a like a TV doc I
wanted to do it in a format and you know
that was back to what mark and myself
discussed we what we wanted to make sure
that you know if we were going to
present this as a theatrical film it
would would be very different and take
you on a journey and here's the thing
because we know it's it's like you know
in classic film trope we know what
happens so the point was to take us on a
journey where we know what how it would
we say in the very beginning what
happens but we still hopefully took you
on a journey that kept you kind of in
suspense I'm not to say that glibly
because you know we are i'm always grows
fully aware and we're doing this than
eleven people died to make this story
possible